kann mich nicht sicher fühlen, weil al
platzierten 22 ihre Zimmerpraktiker
Klang
Ich weiß nicht, ob er morgens aufwachen wird
elia und wird entscheiden, mich essen zu lassen oder zu
töte mich persönlich
Ein Neapolitaner taucht auf der Baustelle auf
Spanisch
bis Sie sich ausdrücklich vorbereiten
von Drogenhandelsbooten
International
also nehme ich mir zeit und mich
Ich wende mich erneut an die Polizei
fragen, was ich tun musste
und das ist, wo die ganze Geschichte von mir beginnt
aber ich fliege die Polizei
dann identifiziert es sie lachen schwarz argos
der Verlorenen werden Fiat-Reste sein
simulierte Transaktionen mit Besteuerung
konnte Ende 7 Tonnen tragen
Kokain schreiben aus der Hölle da
nicht versteckt nicht genau für die versteckt
Tatsache, dass, wenn Sie vor der Polizei fliehen müssen
und wenn du mit dem Entflohenen beladen bist
[Musik]
wenn es keine Möglichkeit mehr gab, zurückzukehren
aus zwei Gründen zurück, einer wegen mir
Ich fand den italienischen Staat auf der einen Seite
dass ich vom Drogenhandel wusste
international also all das
das ist eine kriminelle Vereinigung e
also konnte ich nicht mehr ablehnen
weitermachen, weil ich es hätte tun sollen
an der Seite der Menschenhändler vorbeigehen
[Musik]
auf der anderen Seite konnte ich mich nicht mehr ziehen
zurück, weil sie mich umbringen würden
Es war also ein Laster, das ich nicht mehr konnte
geh zurück
[Musik]